you're saying that you're going to give
up four billion dollars for to avoid a
one in seven chance of killing an
astronaut you're basically saying that
an astronauts life is worth twenty eight
billion dollars hi I'm Matt Welch and
recent TV and I'm joined today by dr.
Robert Zubrin he is an astronaut achill
engineer and occasional contributor to
Reason magazine including in our boffo
space issue Rocket Man in which he wrote
a very popular controversial article
titled what is an astronauts life worth
Robert thank you for joining us why do
you want to kill astronauts I don't want
to kill astronauts i fact I want to
elevate astronauts from their current
status of guinea pigs to their true role
which is as explorers but if they're
going to be explorers they have to be
allowed to explore for the past four
decades nASA has not gone anywhere new
and I think that a major impairment to
astronauts being allowed to do what they
want to do what they need to do what
they should be doing is a safety culture
which has become so risk adverse that it
prevents NASA from fulfilling its
mission given the costs of NASA which
come at the expense of various other
things that we could be doing in the
money whether in the public sector or
the private sector that there's an
obligation for NASA to deliver the goods
here if you say we shouldn't send
astronauts to rescue the Hubble Space
Telescope as former administrator
O'Keefe said because there's risk
involved admittedly a one chance in 50
risk of Space Shuttle failure which was
there documented failure if you've got a
2% chance of killing seven people that
is probabilistically equivalent to a 14%
chance of killing one person and you're
saying that you're going to give up four
billion dollars to avoid a one in seven
chance of killing an astronaut you're
basically saying that an astronauts life
is worth twenty eight billion dollars if
you put this extreme value on the life
of an astronaut you basically make it
impossible to do anything if you say
that safety is your number-one priority
then you never fly and you get a space
agency which is costing 17 billion
dollars a year
and accomplishing nothing and these
calculations happen in other areas of
government they know that number they
follow that according to policy right
right
people have said look we should be
spending that money on real social needs
think of all the lines we could say go
78 billion a year they have a point
there's always something else you could
do there's an infinite series of
expenditures you could do that would
marginally increase the chances of the
astronauts but if you do that you never
fly and you spend an infinite amount of
money to have a space program that
accomplishes nothing and you do this at
the expense of all these other human
needs that could indeed be met it's one
thing you know to spend 4 billion
dollars a year on a shuttle program that
does X Y & Z there's another thing to
spend 4 billion dollars a year on a
manned spaceflight program or currently
10 billion dollars a year on the manned
spaceflight program that doesn't even
launch anyone ok the amount of money
that we are spending on NASA could
indeed be used for other purposes you
name it and therefore they have a
responsibility to perform with that
money if they are not doing that then
what we're basically doing is setting at
naught not only NASA's mission but all
those other human needs it's saying all
those lives that we could save with that
NASA money we don't care about them
we're willing to waste it doing nothing
and all the great goals that NASA should
have opening Mars to humanity that
counts for nothing because we're willing
to spend the money but not do the
mission the mission needs to come first
and on that note we'll close here for a
recent TV I am Matt Welch